what are what have you said when people
ask about the morality of this
you know we we've often uh get this sort
of challenging question of
you know what about the unintended
consequences you know
what if it goes wrong what if science
doesn't get it right
what we have seen is that this concept
of unintended consequences
is quite paralyzing for society it
basically means
don't do anything you don't fully
understand if we really want to
help with the environment right now if
we really want to intervene
we have to actually start designing for
intended consequences
what is it that we want to do that will
be of benefit
as opposed to being paralyzed by the
things that we think
are going to be the greatest risk it's
the biggest problem in politics
is that we're too scared well if you do
that then what happens right it's one of
the reasons we haven't done anything on
climate change
it's like because we're worried about
hurting the companies or hurting xyz or
changing things like well the reality is
we're melting the planet so we better do
something and in that
realm there's a lot of people have made
a very strong moral obligation argument
that because
these species are in trouble from the
things that we did
either intentionally or unintentionally
in ignorance or exploitation
that we have to struggle with paying the
cost
to undo that harm
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
to yang speaks everybody this is your
co-host
zach grauman i was andrew's campaign
manager on the presidential
race and now you're stuck with me as
andrew and myself pursue some political
endeavors outside the realm
of this podcast but i'm glad you're here
april 1st
april fool's day happy april fool's day
today is not an april fool's joke
today is the cloning episode
and it's awesome a couple things one if
you're watching on youtube i got a new
camera a new setup and it looks sick
the background's still working okay
still working on that i don't know what
to put over
yonder back there maybe a plant i'm not
sure but the other thing i'm excited
about i hope you guys are enjoying the
economy opening up a little bit
weather's getting warmer people go
outside and here in new york
people are getting vaccinated in new
york city you're allowed to get
vaccinated over the age of 30
which i am so i'm going to get my
vaccine
um and there's really exciting news that
came out this week the cdc announced i
gotta read this that you
can't carry the virus after you have the
vaccine which is
huge because that's the nightmare people
getting the vaccine and still carrying
coronavirus
so the director of the cdc
said that facts quote vaccinated people
do not carry the virus they don't get
sick she said it on
rachel maddow's show on msnbc and we
know my thoughts on that channel but she
still
is a very credible person to say this
and it's not just in clinical trials she
said but it's also in real world data so
folks
public service announcement as we start
this episode get your vaccine
please and look i had my own hesitations
on this i was like oh should i get the
backs like i don't know i'm pretty
healthy
and get coronavirus it like doesn't
really affect me i've got
whatever it is clean bill of health
that's not the question folks it's not a
question the question is this are you on
team science
or team not science and if you're on
team science
you believe in the vaccine you believe
in science you get the freaking facts
you'll get it
because if you're on team science it's
not just about yourself it's about
others
because if you don't have the vaccine
you can still carry coronavirus and give
it to somebody who may be vaccinated but
could still get it because they're super
vulnerable so don't be stupid
get the facts be on team science that's
the right team get your vaccine
alright simple as that um but more
importantly
today's episode of the future of say
this once
but i really mean it jurassic park
is real yep these guys cloned
a ferret an endangered ferret a
black-footed ferret
that was going extinct and now it's not
because
they cloned it and they've proven you
can do this in other species
and it's wild i've got a conversation
between
basically the leadership of a a
non-listen as a biotech non-profit which
doesn't normally exist those are usually
almost oxymoron because of how expensive
biotech is but it's a biotech nonprofit
called revive and restore
and they use biotech and cloning and
gene splicing
to save endangered species and endanger
ecosystems
for conservation um which is a really
interesting way of looking at things a
lot of times when we
think of conservation it's like save the
pandas uh
save xyz same with amazon but they
are doing that but also using crazy
science
and this is the future um if they can
get this at scale
and inspire a new generation of people
either my age or younger or
even in their you know people making
career moves who get into this space and
put new minds and new research
into this type of technology who knows
what we can do
and it's a little terrifying because
like i said i said i was only going to
say it once but now i'm saying it's life
jurassic park is real they've done stuff
trying to clone wooly mammoths and
trying to
reinvigorate various types of ecosystems
um they talk to me how they struggle
they struggle to clone birds very crazy
wild stuff um so ryan phelan the uh
co-founder and executive director of
revive and restore and her lead
scientist ben novak they both join
ryan is such a badass um and i love
people going on nonprofits who have a
background in entrepreneurship
and uh and biotech in particular just
it's just
it's a pedigree you don't get in the
nonprofit world and
she's clearly kicking ass so sit back
relax and enjoy
the future of conservation the future of
cloning
here on yank speaks
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks i'm beyond
excited we're gonna talk about the
future
of conservation and cloning which i
never thought were two words you would
actually work together there was a new
york times article
that came out and the title said meet
elizabeth ann
the first cloned black-footed ferret
and i looked into this and
it is the first of any native endangered
animal species in north america
to be cloned and i thought
this is jurassic park oh my goodness and
it blew my mind and so i dug in and i
found
the people who did this and they are
here on yang speaks to talk to us guys
and it's very very exciting so
i'm proud proud proud proud to introduce
ryan phelan who is the co-founder and
executive director of an organization
called revive and restore
and the lead scientists of that
organization ben novak
ryan and ben welcome to yank speaks
thanks for being here
well thank you thanks for having us tell
me what what happened
um we'll start with you ryan just let's
let's walk me through this
well i will walk you through but first i
gotta you know temper the enthusiasm
okay i'll calm down this is not bringing
back an extinct species
this is helping to bring in new genetic
diversity
into a species that has been on the
brink
of extinction in fact not once but twice
it was thought to be extinct
um so not to take anything away from how
absolutely
monumental of a milestone this is um
we like to say it's not just about
cloning this is cloning for conservation
because remember 25 years ago at the
roslin institute
in the uk the dolly the sheep was cloned
right it's been 25
years since this has actually been
really applied for conservation
the black-footed ferret was endangered
thought to be extinct did you wake up
one day say we want to clone this
specific animal like how did
how did this start well so first of all
this is a project that has been in the
works for
over seven years and it's a
collaboration between a number of
different partners and i'm going to
start with the u.s
fish and wildlife service so i think
part of the reason why
when you said to me you know how is this
not more newsworthy
this is newsworthy it's newsworthy that
it's a collaboration between a
government
organization in the u.s working under a
federal permit
for endangered species it brought in
for-profit
partners like viagen pets and equine the
leading cloning company
it included the san diego zoo which
uh has something called the frozen zoo
where these cell lines have been banked
for
30 plus years oh wow that's
ready for this well they were ready for
this but you know what's so great
zach because they were ready for this
before they even knew how they could
apply it
right so these species were thought to
be extinct
in the early 80s they were their
original terrain was all across what's
called the great plains of
north america from all the way from uh
the mexico border all the way up into
canada
and uh they became in conflict with
farmers and ranchers who thought they
were a problem on their land they were
over harvested they were
literally extirpated from the land and
these small fragmented populations
you know ended up being in different
clusters finally those
got that we thought winnowed down
completely
so the black-footed ferret in the 80s
um believed to be extinct all of a
sudden a rancher
actually came across one small
family of black-footed ferrets and they
brought them into captivity
because they really believed these were
the final ones and they were
a very smart vet there at the wyoming
uh fish and game service spoke to a
colleague at the san diego zoo
at a chance encounter at a meeting and
the
scientist dr oliver ryder at the san
diego zoo said
if you ever have an opportunity to send
me some skin tissue
from one of these ferrets i would like
to put it in the frozen zoo because we
never know
what we could possibly do to help the
species the san diego zoo
they just have dozens hundreds of
different species that are extinct in
frozen dna in there is that what that is
endangered species are in the frozen zoo
um i think they only have cells from one
or two
species that have gone extinct in the
past couple decades they have more than
one thousand species
and they have tens to hundreds of
of individual cell lines from each of
those species so it's
definitely in the 10 000 range what they
have stored away in these cryo
tanks to ryan's story what's really neat
about bringing elizabeth and this clone
into the world is this year
is actually the 40th anniversary of the
rediscovery
of those black-footed ferrets in wyoming
um
and so it's yeah it's timely it's a very
very interesting milestone
back in 2014 we started working with a
company called cofactor to sequence the
genomes of
willa who is elizabeth anne's uh
clonal mother you know the original and
what we knew about the the population at
that time what the story that got
conveyed to us was that all living
black-footed ferrets which
this breeding season they will reach um
10
000 birthed ferrets over the last 30
uh four years um
and all those ferrets they've read over
the years are descended from just
seven wild individuals that were
captured in the 80s
and uh and willa this these cell lines
came from
an individual that was not one of those
seven
so she could potentially bring in you
know a new gene pool
into this population but she was
captured with those founders so as
unknown as was she somebody's sister
was she you know uh somebody's mother
maybe she's not
actually that unique and no one really
knew how much these
animals had changed over you know 25 30
years of captive breeding
and reintroduction of the wild so we
picked out a few samples to compare the
1980s to the present day
and the results spoke for themselves
willa's genome
has um anywhere but on average
three times more unique variation
than living present-day ferrets and so i
mean that was the
kind of the smoking gun that said if we
bring her back into the population
she's going to infuse it with diversity
i think that this comes to the crux of
why bother doing
this why is this such an important thing
to do yeah when
when these species become so fragmented
and when they become so closely related
inbreeding occurs they become more
susceptible to disease
they start having fewer and fewer
offspring all kinds of things can happen
that make them extremely vulnerable
so if you can actually reverse that
trend
and bring a new genetic variation you
can start to expand that population
and create potentially a much healthier
[Music]
population
all right 2020 showed us a vlog shows a
lot of things but of anything
it showed us that we never know what
life is going to throw at us
and if you use credit cards to pay for
unexpected expenses it can be
overwhelming to manage that debt
so take control with upstart so you can
know exactly
what to expect when you're paying off
credit card debt so upstart is a fast
and easy way to get a personal loan to
pay off your debt
all online so whether that's paying off
credit cards highly consolidated
uh high interest debt funding personal
expenses over a half a million freaking
people have used upstart to get simple
fixed monthly payments they consolidate
all they use lots of different
inputs to evaluate a different type of
credit score for you
they find smarter rates with trusted
partners and they assess more than just
the credit score which i love find out
how upstart can help lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
yang that's upstart.com yang don't
forget to use our url and let them know
we sent you
the loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application that's
upstart.com
[Music]
so how does this
work you had a i'm assuming some genetic
line or some form of dna from the mother
um and then what where do you guys come
in and then and then i'd love to learn
actually how like both the science and
then how the other
players here get involved in that
science too because the bureaucracy of
the science can always be fascinating
too
in a way the nice thing about
communicating cloning is
is it's on paper it's a very simple
technique and it hasn't really changed
since the first animals were cloned in
1957.
um basically you take the
egg cell of a donor mother and you
remove its nucleus its dna
so it's an basically an empty egg cell
at that point
and you take a cell from the animal you
want to clone
and you fuse those together
and that releases the new dna from the
donor
into that egg cell and actually fools
the egg cell into believing it's been
fertilized because now it has a full set
of dna
just like a naturally fertilized animal
would be
and in a petri dish the scientists doing
the cloning they stimulate
growth for you know about a 24 hour
period to get that embryo big enough
to be able to put into a surrogate
mother in the case of
the black-footed ferrets we use the
domestic
ferret as the surrogate mother and the
egg cell donor
and then it's just you know it's
basically what everyone learns about the
miracle of life from there it's
pregnancy and birth which is itself
probably even more complicated than
making the clone
um and more amazing and and that's it in
a nutshell
so the the mother was the ferrets we all
know not a black-footed ferret
and the clone cells were of
the species you're saving am i following
correctly
yeah exactly so so yeah so in the case
of elizabeth ann
we're using the egg cell of a domestic
ferret in order to bring
a cloned black-footed ferret into the
world
and it's it's a really old technique it
actually goes this technique actually
doesn't go all the way back to 1957
being able to take
the eggs of one species in order to give
birth to another
the dna you used had been frozen since
since 1988 i was i was one year old
when willa's cells were frozen
wow where is this done do you guys have
the facilities is it done at the zoo
like and how much equipment is needed to
pull this off is it just as simple like
as a test tube lab is it
crazy frozen is it like the movies like
what what you know my movie i'm thinking
is jurassic park
well the the one the one nice thing
about the cloning process
is that in every science movie science
fiction movie
you see dry ice you see that happen and
that's the one cool thing about this is
that actually happened in this project
so oliver lifts up this the top of the
cryo tank
that the nitrogen gas comes out
ooh there's the cells but then from
there on it's you know it's pretty easy
it's pretty basic
um the cells literally get shipped in a
fedex package
to viagen the company that does the
cloning
and there they take that frozen vial of
cells thaw them out
grow them up in a petri dish um and they
select
some out to make the embryos and at that
point it becomes a veterinary procedure
you know they're implanting into the
surrogate mom so that the disciplines
involved are
are just like you know a lot of other
things but yeah the viagin
is the company that uh did the cloning
and then the neat step in cloning
elizabeth anne is that black-footed
ferrets as ryan pointed out you know
they're endangered we're working with
u.s fish and wildlife service
as an endangered species they are
actually the property and care
of u.s fish and wildlife service so the
pregnant females
halfway through pregnancy were packaged
up into a crate
into a van to stay safe during covid
and driven from new york where they were
made
all the way out to color fort collins
colorado
where they were born how long does
the taking the dna out of the dry ice if
you will
and then getting it getting the um the
egg if you will ready to be placed into
the mother
um how long is that process you know you
know in truth the cloning process itself
particularly for the black-footed
ferrets is not very long
you take the cells out of the vial and
grow them up and it's about maybe two or
three weeks
before you make the embryos to have you
know enough cells to evaluate to make
the embryos
and once you're making the embryos
you're 24 hours away from putting them
into a mother
and in the case of the ferrets that's
then 42 days away from giving birth
so it's it's less than three months
total um start to finish but
you know the you know for we also uh
cloned
a very valuable chevalski's horse from
40 year old cells from the san diego zoo
with the same partners
for the base the same reasons and the
horse pregnancy was 11 months
so much longer process it's all it's all
based on the animal you're working with
the seven and a half years that led up
to elizabeth anne being born was really
actually
doing the genomic study working out the
the steps involved to actually get
permission to do this you know this was
this was a first on many levels for the
the program for the country so there was
a lot to go through to get to that
last little uh major hall
and then of course we were all holding
our breath the week that the labors were
starting how why am i not reading about
this in the new york times
all the time that's a really good
question zach and i think it's important
for us to put
cloning in the right context which is
that
in the best possible world conservation
happens should happen preventively
right you want to be getting species and
to
ensure that they're healthy way before
they start going onto the brink
of extinction there's nothing easy
really about bringing species back from
the brink
it's costly being in this position
is something that you want to do for
only those species that really need help
if you can do all the other preparatory
stuff
and prevent that kind of problem you
want to do it yeah how much does it cost
companies like biogen they have
you know a range of pricing from you
know 50 000 to 100 000 depending on the
species
but uh it in terms of scalability you
don't want to be continually cranking
out clones if you can avoid it
you know there's no question that
natural reproductive
biology is much simpler for all the
animals concerned whether it's a
surrogate
or the actual uh endangered species so
um i think what's really important here
is it
that there are new tools though for
conservation cloning is but one of them
and that is what revive and store is
really focused on trying to demonstrate
how these new emerging tools from
genomics
to synthetic biology to genome
engineering
can actually help species um in these
critical stages
in you know in in the anthropocene
where we have already really intervened
in nature
in many ways in very damaging ways as
with climate change
how can we use these new technologies to
help these species out
until they can be more sustainable on
their own
before i got into politics i was um just
to run a
work on a team called client
philanthropy solutions at ubs and we
used to help families give money to
charities so i worked with a lot of
conservation organizations and the
general
mo of these orgs was to
save them right in the traditional sense
where it's uh
raise money make you feel like watch
cute videos of pandas
and then we're spending money on either
like protected conservation areas of
geography
there's um your literally like there's
some lobbying work that's done to find
poachers and
you know there's a lot of things but
this is the first time i've heard we're
like hey we're using science to save
these
these animals yeah i think zac you're
onto something here there is a natural
tension
that is uh inherent to conservation
which is there's
one camp if i'm going to be really
simplistic here there's one camp that
says
uh let nature take its course let's not
intervene let's protect what we can
um but let's not be too hands-on
there are other conservationists who say
actually we do have to intervene
um and so it's not just about preserving
it's about actually helping species
adapt
a really good example of this right now
is a debate going on
in the uh situation with coral reefs
that are dying
worldwide with warming temperatures
right
and so there are purists who say we
can't mess with them we can't even think
of relocating corals we can't think of
ways to engineer them to adapt to a a
warming environment
and there are those that are saying how
can we not
right we have the ability right
theoretically you know if we know how to
do it
shouldn't we be trying at least before
they're all gone
and so clearly revive and restore is in
the camp of
we need to be proactive not just
precautionary
right we need to be lean into the
situation
and try to figure out can science
actually help
how do you monitor it to know that it
really can
help with an intervention can you look
at it with a long-term
studies and ensure that any kind of
intervention is really going to be
healthy for animals healthy for people
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you once again by outer known guys i
love
this company so it's high quality
clothes with a great fit
it's founded by pro surfer and 11 time
world champion kelly slater
they're high quality they're sustainable
and they are comfy
af holy cow it's like i have a few i
have a pair of jeans and i have this
like
long sleeve like flannel situation and
it's so
comfy yang does all the time he loves
their flannels they're just super comfy
um they look good they fit well and you
know you're doing right
in the world so here's the deal go to
outernown.com today
and enter our code yang at checkout and
you'll get 25 off your first full price
order which is awesome so outernown.com
that's o-u-t-e-r-k-n-o-w-n-dot-com
and remember to use our code yang at
checkout for 25
off check them out today outernown.com
and don't forget
promo code yang 25 off
[Music]
as you evaluate what species to start
saving right like a ferret is one thing
but there's probably others
that maybe can be as insignificant to a
human as a ferret that have a
massive domino effect on an ecosystem
like
i'm so curious how you guys pick and
prioritize
what to clone what to save well i think
there are a couple of things
one as an entrepreneur i'm opportunistic
and so a fair bit of what we're doing is
we're going where there's momentum
where there's a dedicated group of
people
like the fish and wildlife service when
they came to us and said help us with
the black-footed ferret it was like
okay they have a vested interest in this
they're skilled they will be responsible
yeah they have
you know they have people that have
dedicated 30 40 years to the
black-footed ferret it was sort of
you know ben and i walked into that
meeting we thought boy we're really the
newcomers here
um and we still feel that after seven
years
to some degree so um we go where there's
momentum
where there's a will to look at for
innovation and to look for change
and then we're also at the same time
wayne
how important is this for conservation
how impactful
is the species that's at risk is it an
ecosystem engineer
is it a keystone species like coral
that you know everything else all around
it depends on all the fish
um and you know depends on that healthy
environment
and so that becomes kind of a no-brainer
if you could actually
help bring innovation into those areas
you don't just
help in this case the black-footed
ferret you're help
helping all the species that rely on
that ecosystem of the american prairie
the passion for me is is birds i think
that's a passion for
a lot of people i mean there are 45
million birders in the united states
alone
that spend billions of dollars every
year on bird seed and
binoculars and trips to go see birds the
reality is you know there's two there's
two difficult realities i mean i mean
it would it would be amazing to live in
a world where we had unlimited resources
for everything um but the way we've
built our economy and the way we
you know the way we live in the
infrastructure is not that and
conservation
while it seems to be high in the value
list for everybody culturally
it's really low on the value list
economically so how we select what we
work on
i think is is actually the way the whole
field of conservation is working they're
trying to
use limited resources and funds to go
with where there's
will and support and infrastructure and
pick species where you can do the best
amount of good but in truth if we had
all the funds in the world we would work
on everything conserving and making
harmony with everything but birds are
the one
area where there's 11 000 species of
birds in the world
and one out of every eight of them is
threatened with extinction
and we have no technology right now
to do for them what we just did for
black-footed ferrets and schevolsky's
horses
what we're talking about doing with
coral reefs we have none of it
because all because the reproductive
technique to be able to take that
embryo in a petri dish and make it into
an animal
it's not there it all has to do with the
hard
shelled egg so this is probably a
problem that extends to reptiles as well
um but yeah we and you know i was
brought on to revive and restore to
bring the passenger pigeon back to life
um
and the problem in biotechnology when it
comes to birds is what comes first the
bird or the egg
well it's the egg and the egg is a
problem but
if we literally crack that egg
and make the right omelette we open up
genetic rescue for
for a whole host of species why doesn't
the science work the same way when it's
a hard shell egg
when we cloned elizabeth anne the ferret
and kurt the chevalsky's horse
the embryos were made in a petri dish
just like
just like thousands of people alive
today who were made by in vitro
fertilization right you make an embryo
and then you implant it into a mother on
birds there's no mother to implant into
you have to get that embryo into an egg
and
the way the egg forms inside of the
mother bird
around the embryo just complicates the
matter that when an egg is laid the
embryo is already partly growing up
so you can't go from that single cell
embryo
and go right into an egg the other
difficult part is to do something like
cloning
the issue is what not a lot of people
know about eggs the yolk
you crack open an egg and eat it that
entire yolk is
one cell the orange part in an egg
is one cell the yolk of eggs are the
largest
biological cells in the world and you'll
notice that they're opaque
and their little dna is floating around
somewhere in that thick yoke
you have to be able to find that to
remove it to be able to actually
make a cloned embryo so just doing that
it's like a physical challenge
too it's a physical challenge yeah
however
once the egg is laid and that embryo is
a little growing up
it is an environment that is so much
more accessible than a uterus
um in a mammal like you can you can
literally
chop the top off of an egg and pour a
baby out into another egg and it will
hatch you can hatch it out of saran wrap
you can do all kinds of manipulation to
a bird
once it's grown up to a certain point
but it's those early stages that are
inaccessible
so bird bio genetic rescue could really
explode
but we have to make this one
breakthrough first
[Music]
okay if you're like me if you don't get
a good night's sleep
the rest of the day and sometimes the
rest of the week is horrific it's one of
the most powerful ways to improve your
overall health
and happiness get a good night's sleep
and if your daily routine has
changed it can be harder to fall and
stay asleep and that's why we are
sponsored by
calm it's an app designed to ease stress
and get the best sleep of your life and
when you relieve anxiety improve your
sleep you feel
better in every part of your life
they've got a whole library of programs
designed to help you sleep you just open
the app
press the button you get sleep stories
or soothing voices and all this
beautiful things coming out of it it's i
love it it helps me sleep
you go to calm.com you'll get a limited
offer of 40
off one of the calm premium
subscriptions which is hundreds
of hours of programming so for our
listeners of the show we're offering a
special limited time promotion of 40
off of a calm premium subscription at
calm.com
yang that's 40 off unlimited access to
calm's entire library
and new content is added every week so
get started today at calm.com that's
calm.com
yang
what do what have you said when people
ask about the morality of this in that
you know people say you're you're either
playing god but i don't really care
about that
part so much but more of that this is
amazing technology that could be
potentially used in the wrong hands or
wrong purposes or even accidentally be
strange like what do you what do you
guys think of that and
how do we control for that and what are
your thoughts it's hard for me to
imagine a scenario
that's really dark um about these
technologies i think the
the the moral issue that people do get
concerned about is
animal welfare and um you know
there are people that feel that it's
immoral to have zoo
animals in captivity period um
and so you know i believe that
um more and more zoos worldwide are
very focused on conservation uh and in
fact they're
a major contributor to conservation
because very often
the breeding of those animals that are
done in zoos then get
reintroduced to the wild and so they're
they play a very important part of that
that conservation ecosystem
it can't happen without those animals in
captivity
so i think it's always a question of do
you care about the
individual animal more than the
collective
population or the collective species as
a whole
um and so yes maybe
some animals may suffer individually
through some of this process
and in some of this experimentation but
if you're doing it
in order to ensure that the population
survives
um i think you got to look at the the
greater good
the the welfare issue is actually why we
use the domestic ferret
um to clone elizabeth and that's why we
use a domestic horse to clone
the wild chevalski's foal is because
domestic species have been living
with human beings for thousands of years
for the purposes we've bred them to do
their welfare is well accounted for
and you know it takes a surrogate mother
it takes an egg donor to make these
animals
black-footed ferret females are best
used
just breeding more offspring rather than
being donors so if
so that was the big reason why we go to
a domestic species something that we
know we can give really great welfare to
in captivity and then bring a new
valuable animal into
an endangered species but on that zoo
concept that ryan brings up you know
if it wasn't for zoos and captive
breeding black-footed ferrets
condors whooping cranes kakapo would all
be extinct today
the people behind this when you really
meet people working in zoos who do this
and the people doing conservation
animal welfare issues of the individuals
they're at their
their hearts like people bond with these
animals
and and they're doing an amazing job uh
today
unlike any generation before to make
sure that we can save species
without incurring costs like uh but it
but it's true there's a pragmatic aspect
to it that we have to just
at the end of the day say what do we pay
to save a species and what is the value
of an entire species worth
and and in that realm there's a lot of
people have made a very strong moral
obligation argument that because
these species are in trouble from the
things that we did either intentionally
or unintentionally
in ignorance or exploitation
that we have to struggle with paying the
cost
to undo that harm you know we we've
often uh get this sort of challenging
question of
you know what about the unintended
consequences you know
what if it goes wrong what if science
doesn't get it right
um and uh what we have seen is that this
concept of unintended consequences is
quite paralyzing for society
it basically means don't do anything you
don't fully understand
don't do anything that you know you've
got these unknown unknowns out there
until you answer them you can't proceed
and
um we did this amazing workshop and at
the end of the day
um it became really clear that if we
really want to
help with the environment right now if
we really want to intervene
we have to actually start designing for
intended consequences
what is it that we want to do that will
be of benefit
as opposed to being paralyzed by the
things that we think
are going to be the greatest risk so
finding that balance
is both a moral cultural economic shift
for a lot of people
to think through where do they put their
time their energy their money
for conservation so the biggest problem
in politics is that we're too scared
well if you do that then what happens
right it's one of the reasons we haven't
done anything on climate change
it's like because we're worried about
hurting the companies or hurting xyz or
changing things like well the reality is
we're melting the planet so we better do
something
[Music]
all right this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by stamps.com let's face
it taking trips to the post office is
probably not
how you want to spend your time and
that's why we recommend shipping online
at stamps.com which allows you to mail
and ship anytime anywhere right from
your
computer letters packages you name it
and you pay a lot less with discount
rates from usps ups
and more i'm a fan of this anytime i
need to mail something just stamps.com
very simple underneath the post office
save time save money
you can do it 24 7 any letter any
package any class of mail anywhere
wherever you send so here's the deal
it's a freaking no-brainer so stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with our promo code yang
you get a special offer includes a four
week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts so just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone
top of the homepage type in
yang.stamps.com promo code
yangstamps.com
never go to the post office again
so what what does the future look like
what and
like i'd love to talk about two two
pieces of that what what's exciting you
and then what what could be scary kind
of the unintended content what are the
downside risks that could be scary let's
start with what's exciting you what does
this look like 10
20 years from now 50 years from now what
are we looking at before talking about
the next 20 to
50 to 100 years is we're living in an
amazing
future of conservation right now like
getting back to this issue of intended
and unintended consequences
people have been doing intended
conservation for a long time you can
we looked at just one one part of
conservation
just the movement of wildlife from a zoo
to the wild from one location to another
that's been going on for 125 years in
the united states
and the track record is
99.99999
successfully beneficial unintended
consequences that people have feared for
decades and continue to fear
just haven't bore out like the fear that
they won't integrate
the tiger won't integrate back into the
wild exactly these fears have not bore
out
and and uh and so looking to the future
if we look at just right now compared to
where we were
at the beginning of conservation and you
think of the amazing way we can bring in
biotechnologies
we're living in a in a world that is
proof that conservationists do good work
responsibly they think about the risks
and they mitigate and anticipate those
they save species and we take a lot of
it for granted
you know out here on the east coast
whitetail deer are everywhere
120 years ago they were on the verge of
extinction
and today they are a conservation
success story nobody talks about that
because
that all happened before we ever had an
endangered species act before we were
you know really aware of all this stuff
so the history of conservation
is we're already in it you add
biotechnology to that with the people
behind the wheel that are good drivers
of this
and there's so many amazing things we
could do actually make sure that we
don't lose coral reefs in the next 50
years
bring back species into environments
that are so valuable
that you know that we've never been able
to before that we can re-diversify the
planet
keep genetics going and really in my
opinion
create a future where there's equity and
balance in how
humans of every walk of life can enjoy
and live in harmony
every walk of their day with the
millions of other species on this planet
man i love that answer i think i'm
learning here in some ways that in order
to be
in the conservation business you kind of
have to be
some form of an optimist you know
because it's such a forward-looking
futuristic hope for a better future
business industry
yeah think about it oliver ryder
froze the will the cells of willow 33
years ago
with the hope they'd be used someday you
know that's optimism
to its core good point and that's
conservation it's it's about being
pragmatic today
with an optimistic spirit that you're
going to win and you keep working until
you win and i think ryan
you know if i can say for all of us
that's why intended consequences
is such a huge paradigm shift that's
important because
if all you're thinking of is how can
this go wrong and it's going to go wrong
and we're
doomed and you think in fear you give up
and conservation has been a success
story of perseverance that
you keep going till you get success
that's how businesses are made that's
how politicians win
candidacies that's how we save species
and biotech is going to give us ways to
do that that we've never had the
ability to do before um and so you know
i would love it if there was a flood of
movies and tv shows that stopped
peddling the dystopian future of
biotechnology
because everyone we know using it is
doing it
to do something amazing and good in this
world
and and so when you ask what are we
scared of or what are the unintended
consequences
i can't think of any that are serious
because
the nature of this field is about doing
something that's going to have benefit
it's such a good point where it's
there's so much
there's not a lot of quick wins in your
world you know what i'm saying where
it's like so much work and energy and
trial and error
so like let's talk about like the evil
doer who's the bad guy in avatar who's
minding the new planet for whatever or
you know that's what like human beings
think of when they think of this right
that human in your space is going to
have a lot of barriers
to prevent them from being the bad guy
because it's so hard and time consuming
um so that actually is really uplifting
and
ultimately zach none of this technology
goes forward
without social license we have a
regulatory environment as soon as you're
working with endangered species it has
to be complied with um
but you know increasingly what we're
hearing
throughout our culture right now is that
people of all different walks of life
bear relationship to nature whether it's
in their own backyard or it's out
at the top of a mountain somewhere when
they're skiing
everybody comes at it from a different
perspective and they all
have a common right to care about what's
going on in their environment
allowing those voices to be heard giving
it
permission for them to actually have a
voice
in how we interact with nature
is going to be a real important part of
the equation and it's something that i
think will build in
this patience in a sense that you're
calling for in conservation it can't
happen fast
um you know these species have been on
the planet for thousands of years
and what we want to do is keep them on
this planet for
the next millions of years so to do that
um we have to have the long the long
term thinking in place the long goal so
you guys both mentioned you mentioned
coral you've mentioned
birds what else and that's not to say
that's not a lot of work but what else
is next
in the the ryan ben save the world
universe
uh what else is exciting you down the
the near term
so we've just um started a pretty new
initiative this last year called wild
genomes
and we're um actually funding
researchers around the world
to vote to do to do two things
to sequence a particular species that
they're working on
to do full genome sequencing or
reference genomes
and to cryopreserve those species
for the future so in doing this
we've we set up a criteria for them and
we said basically you can apply for
funding
to accomplish this assuming that you
are going to apply it for conservation
so this is not just an academic exercise
i want to know everything about
the evolution of a particular just learn
you have to use it
you have to use it and you have to
demonstrate to us in your proposal
that understanding how the jaguar is
moving in north america across state
lines
by looking at the sequence data is going
to be very compelling for the protection
of that species or whatever the
uh the issue is that that particular
species is fake
facing and we've done it both for
terrestrial species
as well as marine species and what we're
finding is that there are
young researchers and not so young
researchers
all over the world that have not yet
had an opportunity to deploy the benefit
of genomic technology it's you know it
is not
ubiquitous at all in conservation and it
should be
it's getting cheap enough accessible
enough
and that's part of what revive and
restore is really excited about
is enabling this with researchers all
over the world
so you're going to help these young
researchers use the technologies that
let's call it 2 10 20 years ago
researcher in the past which has been
great
had did not have the access to and now
we do and it's cheaper and more
effective and faster
exactly and it can tell them all kinds
of things it can
explain everything about how that
population is doing
in terms of their genetic variation like
the black-footed ferret
it can be viewed to help be an indicator
of
other health issues it can help them
understand the population structure
um it can you know we're looking at it
for the potential to
identify uh invasive species to identify
um particular targets for other aspects
that would even include genome
engineering
to eradicate an invasive species or
whatever
so uh it's pretty compelling but it is
genomic sequencing is it is the
fundamental
baseline that we would like to see in
the conservation toolbox
uh to deploy that today is really i
think imperative
yeah we're actually completely unique in
that space there are a lot of
and i'm gonna ask who's doing this
because i did do some
let's call it dumb guy research on
what's going on in this space
and i found you and that's about it some
governmental programs i guess but what
like what does the landscape
like we've become the rome of of genetic
rescue okay
all roads lead to us somehow um because
of the amazing people we've been able to
make networks with
um the but you know we learned early on
that
biomedicine is just you all you hear
about in biomedicine anymore is genomes
genomes genomes
and conservation that's just not where
they're at
and and there are so many projects going
we're going to sequence
every bird genome we're going to
sequence every uh
vertebrate genome but they're not doing
it in a way that
translates that information into action
and they're not targeting endangered
species they're just doing what they can
because it's hard
it took as we said seven years to work
with a black-footed ferret
there are there are necessary
protections in place to be able to work
with these species
and so we say you know what we're gonna
we're gonna enable the young people and
even veterans out there that want to do
this
and start making this show the world
that you can do this and improve
conservation through it and i think
what's also unique about this fund is
we're kind of hoping that we can
eventually work ourselves out of a job
in this one because
it would be great if after 10 or 15
years or less
of funding these amazing projects
that governments around the world that
leaders actually look at it and go you
know what
these are things we can be funding these
researchers to do that new revenue
sources come in
uh because yeah you know the future of
genetic rescue and conservation
is really in the hands of politicians
and leaders
in our world um and so far
uh uh you know it's been pretty dismal
how much attention is given to the
future of an entire world
and new generations of humans to come
over the
the exploitations that we think matter
right now in the four-year
political cycle you've just said a lot
of things that i loved when i was
a philanthropy advisor is that you're
you're funding research you're funding
other people you're partnering
you've got a lot of other organizations
um and you're trying to work yourself
out of a job
um those are three main things a lot
you're taking risks right like those are
things a lot of non-profits do not do
how can the yang gang how can our
listeners how do they find you guys it's
the easiest best way to support you
um what's helpful so revive and restore
is as you have said
we're a non-profit 501c3 we're open to
donations
um our website is very simple revive
restore.org and
we would you know welcome uh engagement
with more people from all over the world
both ryan and ben um thank you
congratulations
on um elizabeth ann and all of the work
you're doing
i am excited i've said this everybody's
come on the future i've said 10 years
i'll reach out to you and see what else
you guys have
birthed to the world and what other
technologies have now put a dent in the
universe its own way but
um keep doing what you're doing we are
behind you and thank you for
for joining
[Music]
you